delivering on the dream of self-driving
cars requires a lot endless Road testing
computer modeling and robotics expertise
and sometimes dressing up as a car seat
to spook teens
this man is no mischief maker he's part
of a study into how humans can interact
with driverless vehicles the research
funded by Ford and run by the Virginia
Tech Transportation Institute in August
may seem silly but it's an effort to
answer a key question how should
self-driving cars communicate with the
people around them eliminating the
driver eliminates the visual cues eye
contact a wave of the hand an extended
middle finger that human drivers used to
interact with pedestrians cyclists and
others on city streets studying this is
tricky because everyone testing robo
cars on public streets puts an engineer
behind the wheel to ensure the car
doesn't do something stupid thus the
human driver disguised to look like he's
not actually there for this study the
researchers hooked up their Ford van
with a light display and a new code of
the road to white lights moving side to
side means the car will stop a rapidly
blinking white light means it's about to
start up again the idea for it says is
to create a new international language
of sorts or at least an industry
standard for autonomous car
communications the researchers collected
150 hours and 1,800 miles of driving
data
now they'll crunch the numbers to
discover if they've hit on the Esperanto
of 80s even if nothing comes of this
study at least they've got a sweet
Halloween costume